i you know i can rag on the media
forever it's crazy how
you guys you're literally just there the
whole time
be it through any one of these rights or
particularly like the more severe crazy
ones like kenosha
and the news crews they're gone i'm
curious the people listening
have any have you ever thought about the
fact that when you see one of these
twitter videos
there's no news cruise anywhere yeah
yeah like
i don't know what you guys think like
you're the only ones down there i think
part of it is because uh
the media is a really like these
protesters
and riders do not like the media so if
you come in with a big camera
and a legitimate crew the chances that
you
get forcibly pushed out are high
we've seen it multiple times before
and so what we do is we go in much more
low-key with literally
our cell phones and try to be
as you know discreet as possible because
um they don't they don't want media
there
right right and and the difference is
that a lot of these outlets will say
okay you know what it's too dangerous
let's just leave but
it's part of the story and i think
that's that's the other issue i have
with a lot of people in the media is
that they say that
you know uh conservatives are are
overblowing the violence but when it's
happening night after night in multiple
cities it's part of the story
and then you know even on my very first
night
you know ever actually reporting for
daily caller on the job
i believe it was uh that it was like may
29th and
the white house goes on lockdown and it
was like i believe it was like 12 15 i
remember it
and our producer sean you know he
messaged me and says hey we need a
reporter on the ground
he's like what'd you go i know you're
you know you just started i was like i
was like i'll get an uber right now and
as soon as i got to the ground
at lafayette you know square it was it
was you know hectic
the the crowd was was going crazy and
you know i was setting up my phone on
this like little cell phone tripod and
as i'm setting it up
i could hear uh leland brett from fox
news you know getting ready to do his
live shot
and he as soon as he says i'm legally
right with fox news you could just hear
the whole crowd say
watch news and then that's when they all
go you know to attack him they like
stole his mic they threw it back at him
and then this is my very first time ever
reporting for the daily caller so i was
like
i just turned my phone on i hit record
and then i started doing like some
narration and then you know leland was
able to make it to the police
and i just posted it on twitter and i
think like an hour or two later
the clip was at like 200k views wow then
i then the next morning i woke up to
like you know fox playing it tucker
wanted it
but right there it that was my first
experience saying wait you know this
this game is is different now because
you know i i went to school where you
know i majored in broadcast journalism
like the old school style where like
when you go when you go report a story
you dress nice you look good your
your hair is combed over and i learned
and i learned really quick i'm like you
know what this is going to be a
different style journalism that i was
taught of the whole dressing night we're
going to have to
adapt and right there at that first
night how like shelby said is
we kind of learned like hey we can't we
can't approach this you know how how we
used to
aren't you mad that you wasted all that
money yeah going to school
just go out there with a cell phone and
like tucker carlson's like let me run it
man it's was that uh was that that
fateful day where trump did the photo op
no that was a few days
before that oh okay yeah the lockdown
happened later yeah yeah
then yeah so so seeing you know leland
get attacked was
was pretty crazy nice and i believe
about two or three weeks after that
shelby actually uh got got attacked when
we were we were reporting on building
plaza show you want to speak about that
experience yeah
so uh we were it was sort of a tense
situation there was a line of police and
then a line of
protesters or writers i i don't know if
unrest people whatever you call it
unrest yeah
on arresters yeah i don't know how you
know
perfect uh and a group came
with shields and they were all moving to
the front of the
line so that the police had shields and
they had shields and so
naturally i roamed over and started to
film and
um a group of girls accused me of being
an undercover cop
and i was like i'm not not pretty sure
i'm not an undercover cop
but they didn't believe me and and i one
or two
protesters were actually trying to calm
the situation down i showed them
like my bio i showed them you know my
twitter to show them
you know who i was and one of them was
like yeah okay she is who she says she
is and they're like
delete the footage um stop filming and
i you know am uh irish catholic
like short-tempered like yeah
you know if you tell me to do something
i'm probably just gonna do the exact
opposite
so i well i stayed because
it was sort of i also knew that a lot of
media will just leave and i feel like
that's really wrong and you can't let
you know this is my job and you can't
be bullied into something and so they
started pushing me around
shoving me one of the girls grabbed my
phone she was on the ground
um like with her i think one of my
co-workers was like prying her fingers
off of my phone and
and i got shoved into the police line
actually and the police pulled me
through
wow and then they handcuffed me you guys
have like special phones when you go
down that
like nope this is my only phone that's
why i fought for like i was not letting
go of this phone i was like this is
this is my baby you know you you
definitely gotta get like a burner a
second phone yeah it's something
interesting that's a good idea
from my perspective though because um
basically that you know police
you wanna start real quick yeah well
yeah sorry i gotta tell this story from
my perspective because
um shelby and i were right there
on the police lines things were kind of
settled down actually the police had
pushed everybody out of the area and you
know they were set up and so there were
just two lines of
of protesters on wresters and registers
and uh and i'm actually talking
negotiating a content deal
trying to make you know trying to keep
everybody employed and shelby's like hey
i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go over there with uh matt and
vince and i'm like oh yeah you're good
okay cool
and i'm on the phone and i just i hear
all this yelling and i turn
and i just see shelby behind police
lines handcuffed
just screaming wow and i was like uh
yeah i think i gotta go
i remember that i think there was a
video of you like getting cuffed right
yeah and people were freaking out like
why are they handcuffing her
no that was the second time we got
arrested no no no i remember i remember
saying like it was bs that you got
handcuffed because oh yeah yeah yeah
you're being attacked
but then you guys got arrested recently
and
so my my initial reaction to you guys
getting arrested so uh
just like uh well yeah i'll just start
i'll just start from the beginning
when i heard that you guys got arrested
i saw a bunch of people on twitter
tweeting like this is bs they're
arresting journalists
and i gotta be honest i was laughing you
know why because this happens all the
time
journalists get arrested they get shoved
by cops like i've got friends who are
reporting in portland
and they're standing inside where the
cop will come and shove them it happens
it does
and all of a sudden now to see people
who normally have never tweeted about it
like
sounding just like these other left-wing
journalists it's a legitimate i'm not
trying to disrespect anybody i'm saying
like
now we're seeing conservatives be like
whoa and then my reaction was like you
know what man look
it's chaotic you got antifa pretend to
be press
and then the cops are like there's a big
crowd in front of me i have no idea who
you are
everybody's getting arrested and i've
been in this situation but when
your guys boss called them up and said
yeah the reporters and the police
refused to cut you loose
that's when i was like now that's some
bs yeah you can make a mistake
and i'm willing to be like well fine
mistakes happen
but i don't know you guys want to tell
the story about what went down when you
got arrested
covering the ante for riots yeah well
i think shelby should start because her
starting point is a little bit more
interesting than mine because she was
like a block away from
the police unit right shelby yeah so uh
well
earlier in that night uh two police
officers had been shot
this is louisville in louisville um and
and the police shooting happened
i want to say a mile or so away from the
protest area
which is where we were ultimately
arrested and so i was
near the hospital
i had just recorded uh the chief of
police had
done an update you know the two officers
were alive and one was in
surgery and uh then i headed back to the
protest area
and it was you know after curfew but
press are
exempt from the curfew and exempt from
unlawful assemblies because
you know it's it's news and this is our
job and
there was a really long line of police
officers and sort of a scattered
protester crowd and the police were
telling them to disperse and after
i want to say 10-15 minutes they they
did appear to be leaving they
they roamed down the block and some of
them went left some of them went right
and that's when the police just
came from all sides um
and i just started recording and
apparently one of the police officers
said that
we were running from the police and i
have a video of
me literally just standing walking
around in a circle like
police are corralling everyone in and
then
yeah the kettle and then um we were told
to get on the ground and i recorded that
too
so i got on the ground they were like
put your
real quick she got a watermark on the
video as she was getting arrested i did
that's yeah that's somebody you want
working for you i was told that we have
to have watermarks on our videos
so i you know i in the video you can see
i'm saying you know we're press we're
press
um and we the the first big issue was
that we didn't have press credentials on
us and so
i knew that we were likely going to be
taken in but i also knew
or i assumed because i had already told
my boss
and everyone who worked at the caller i
knew that they were calling already
to get us out and so i i assumed we were
not even going to be processed because
it was very clear like jeff my our
editor-in-chief you know provided ample
evidence that we were who
we said we were in i ended up getting
processed getting charged with two
misdemeanors
unlawful assembly and failure to
disperse and i was held for 16 hours
and then uh you got a rest at the same
time in the same case yeah so you know
got arrested with shelby uh you know we
ended up getting split
um the my arresting officer was like he
actually believed that i was pressed
like i had like a little press thing on
me
and he was like at least trying he was
at least trying to talk to his officers
on what to do with me but
he at the end of the day you know it
wasn't his call and then we get into the
uh
into like we're about to get processed
or like chained up with everyone
and then like a sergeant or like a chief
like a higher up
comes into that that section and says
you know he yells my name
uh jorge ventura i said you know i
raised my my hand and he he brought me
over he says hey
um i'm on the phone with your
editor-in-chief you are accredited media
or eventually and your partner you know
he says shelby's name
and he says just hold on one sec so when
he walks back so
for me i was already doing like a
celebration dance i was like i'm getting
out
yeah we're out i'm like we're i was
trying to find shows like we're out of
here
this is this is awesome he then
literally just comes back and was like
hey we're going to charge you two
misdemeanors you're going to stay at
night in jail we give you you know
several
attempts to leave the unlawful assembly
and you did it and i was just like
what's what's the what are the
misdemeanors
you guys have the same ones no yeah
mines was like local county ordinance
and then uh you know failure to disperse
and then hurt unlawful assembly and
failure to disperse
yeah so for a second i'm the worst
criminal
yes so it was it was it sucked for me
because i actually i got the high of
thinking we're going to escape
he just doubled down third a third
reporter
drew hernandez was also arrested and i
had been
already at this point when i saw him
come through i had been chained
they had like a you know they had us
chained up literally like dogs it was
it was like by around the neck no like
there there was a lot there was like a a
chain link
line with like multiple handcuffs and we
were all just
handcuffed next to each other on the
same chain
for like two and a half hours you know
um and
drew walked by and mouthed to me that
someone was
on the phone so he must have been right
next to jorge and so i assumed at that
point that i was getting released
so then shortly after the female officer
who had arrested me came and
and uncuffed me and and two girls next
to me started cursing at me
um asking me you know white privilege
why who
who am i and they were white but
you know who am i why am i being why am
i being taken away and i thought i was
getting released so i was just like i'm
a reporter and they
went crazy and then i ended up being in
the cell with one of them
which made me nervous yeah but i can
only imagine being chained to those
people
is like the scene from dumb and dumber
where i don't you have you seen this
am i too old where yeah like the dudes
in the middle of uh
jim carrey and jeff daniels and they're
going like screaming in his ears
man i could i could it was a mixed bag
there were some girls crying
some girls were just sitting there like
this is what's happening
some girls were very angry but every
time one of the girls moved we'd all
move because we were all handcuffed
together and the girl who was hit they
ran out of handcuffs so they started
handcuffing us like i was zip tied and
handcuffed with one handcuff
and the girl behind me was using the
other handcuff and she was like six
inches taller than me
so my like shoulder was like it was yeah
oh man so so
how many of the men were crying in
yourself well no
no men were crying in mine but well hold
on that's weird
were you crying men and women or you
know i had oh but i was in there with
you know small cell one bathroom with
with 40 men
yeah so i go wait wait wait wait wait
were you chained together well we were
be
at at first you then then we go into
soap but before you know when we were
chained up i still had my phone so i was
like oh no i was like taking pictures
and like using my phone and then i would
look at children she was just like
were you like in the same holding cell
like across so when
first before they processed everyone
they arrested over 100 people that night
so they were like a mess
so we were like there was one line of
people chained up that were females
another line were females another line
of men
and then once we got processed we went
into holding cells and that was
separated and
my holding cell was like off in a corner
so we couldn't even see the men
i think you you guys were across from
another female holding cell
um was anybody singing oh yes
actually i knew it at one point at one
point there was one
nurse who was kind of nice to us and and
they named her miss jackson
and they started doing that i'm sorry
i'm not going to sing for people
you know yeah and then at another time
they started
screaming blm chance no you can't stop
the revolution and then they
decided to stop because they didn't want
to be charged with inciting a riot
inside of jail
oh wow yeah i don't know if that's a
thing but they were like you should
probably yeah
well i don't know but i know singing is
a thing like they always sing
and i would just be like look man i've
been
uh i've been arrested i think i can off
the top of my head i remember
two incidents uh two instances but i've
never been processed so
i was in st louis i got arrested and
this is really really annoying to me
that there's like
even there's like it doesn't matter what
political uh faction people are involved
in they don't understand what a rest
means
so i literally an officer say you are
under arrest
cuff me sit me down and then
half an hour later you have press
credentials pull my wallet take a look
uncuff me and say get out
that's an arrest it's not detained
detained there's different there's
different legal uh uh
there's legal distinctions there and
then i was in dc
when uh they surrounded this whole group
of like 250 people
and i was standing on the sidewalk and
there was like this stair set
it's like two or three stairs this was
uh the j-20
rioting in in washington dc for trump's
inauguration and all of these people
just like run full speed past the cops
they're like knocking cops down cops are
spraying everybody
and i just like back off now is the
mistake the cops surround
everybody in this little space that i
was in and so the first thing i did
was i went to the far edge of where the
police
like were lined up so i was like
literally standing next to the cop and
staying away from the people screaming
and then i just asked one guy for a
supervisor and they like wouldn't really
give me any attention because they're
like standing their batons out
and then someone like finally one of the
cops nods and then like you know i guess
whisper somebody
the lieutenant comes over and i was like
i'm holding my press card i want to let
you know i'm pressed and he goes don't
care everybody hears you're
under arrest you are not free to go and
that's just what's happening and i was
like dude dude i know i know
just letting you know that's all that's
all i'm saying and so then finally
he comes back over and that there was
like a news crew like was like an nbc
crew and they had a camera
and he and he looked at him and he you
know fingered you know come over here
and then the cops move out of the way
and then i immediately like pop up
behind him and i hold up my card and the
guy looks at me and he
fans me over and then he was like show
me your press cards and then i did and
they pulled out
a small handful of the journalists a
couple of the journalists that were in
there
were screaming at the top of their lungs
at the cops you mother
after i'm effing press what gives you
the right they got arrested
i was sitting there like with my hands
up just like chilling
and i was like you know the cop that was
next to me was like agitated and looking
and out and whenever i was doing
something i'd let him know that
i'm just going to go in my background my
cell phone just want you to know that
like nods
because he doesn't know what these
people are doing so i'm like trying to
be very you know
careful of that but so i've never been i
say this because i've never been
actually brought down to the station
with these people and i'm
eternally grateful cause i'll tell you
what i've been arrested for
skateboarding before and i got charged
they they wanted to get me on a felony
which is like just ridiculous over the
top
he was riding his skateboard and
downtown chicago so we're gonna throw
the book at him
ultimately the judge like got really
angry because they ended up giving me a
misdemeanor but
the judge got super angry when you found
out but so i'm sitting when i got
arrested i got put in this concrete
block
the lights are on full blast there's
like no water it's just you go in a room
and there's a concrete block to sit on
and the only thing i could hear was some
guy whaling who was like probably mental
mentally unwell
i can deal with all that i can
absolutely i can sit down there i can
fold my legs and i can you know do some
some zen meditation or whatever and just
zone out and be like i can sit through
this i can endure
but i tell you what man if you put a
couple hundred like antifa leftist
singing kumbaya
i'd probably bash my skull against the
wall that'd be the end i will say
i think that i did much better
with these people in with me granted
they didn't know
where i worked because i was genuinely
afraid of
saying where i worked so they asked me
and i said i was a freelancer
um and then they asked me who i was
freelancing for and i set up
just freelancing for free yeah you just
say
well we we just we just sell it
afterwards
because it is a gent like we have been
targeted and that's like a genuine
concern and i think that was a really
big concern
that the caller to the police department
and it didn't matter
so just for everybody who's listening
daily caller that's tucker carlson's
outlet right yeah is he still involved
or he like stepped down he
sold his shares to um neil patel so
interesting yeah but it's still
associated yes but you know he founded
it i guess is that what it is yeah neil
patel is
tucker's car college roommate oh and
that's where we founded it together in
2010.
okay that's not weird i was like selling
your company to your college roommate
it's like an interesting oh wait they
started together because they're friends
that i get
yeah but uh i will say actually
um i think that louisville was
more blm focused than antifa focus that
was one of the cities
you know compared to portland i would
say is more antifa focused
so it was the message was a lot clearer
in louisville than in some other cities
where i feel like they're just
destroying things for no reason and you
know what i mean
and there wasn't as much destruction in
louisville as i thought
and i think and actually my cellmates
agreed with me they were like
you know we thought the city was going
to burn and there were distraught there
were
you know things broken into and and but
it wasn't like
it was in or minneapolis um
but i will say that some of these some
of the people that were in there
definitely deserve to be in there i
think one of them broke
a police officer's hand whoa
well she said she didn't but i don't
know uh but some of them
uh you know seemed like they really were
against you know violent protests they
were
um you know more for peaceful stuff and
they did have
you know legitimate stories and messages
to share
so that was interesting because it was
it sort of opened up
my eyes to a different side of
the protest that you don't see as much
and they don't really give you the
ability to see because they don't like
media
and they like to press and it also
opened my eyes to just how bad
jail is i would not recommend yeah
um like i didn't realize you know if you
don't always get water when you want
water
like the toilet was right by the window
where actual inmates could like watch us
and luckily we devised a plan we had a
blanket and anytime someone would need
to pee
they'd that's like it's a very common
thing for
the people when they're when protesters
get arrested yeah these techniques yeah
so if you if you're lucky enough
to be a journalist getting arrested with
one of the organizers
they know exactly how to work we had an
organ we had one or two organizers
in our in our cell with us and it was
eye-opening i mean
horrible and i like almost lost my mind
i'm serious like
not knowing the time for 16 hours it
messes with you
i it was and the fact that i knew that
they knew that i was
pressed and i was still not being
released i thought was a real
failure um in the justice system whoever
it was that was
you know allowed to release us i was
really disappointed do you think you're
stronger now having experienced it
yes i think and i think i have
um different i i've it's
again opened up a whole different
sort of aspect of these protests of the
justice system
that i have i've never seen before
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you